what are the leadership qualities
required to be President of the United
States the question should be what are
the leadership qualities required to be
a good president of the United States
you know in our political environment to
become president is a is a little bit of
a game and it requires money and it
requires personality and the willingness
to withstand a brutal brutal election
process but to be a really good
president the United States requires
vision
it requires idealism and a commitment to
that idealism if you look back to the
inaugural speeches of both Ronald Reagan
or JFK so you can pick your you can pick
your politics it doesn't matter in both
of their inaugural addresses they both
use the world the words peace on earth
world peace
they both fundamentally believed in this
ideal that is world peace
and they wanted to advance America to
help build that world these days when
those terms are used if they're used at
all it's usually as a punch line those
two leaders fundamentally believed in it
so to be a good leader of the United
States as two things one a vision of the
future that is better than the victim
the version that we're living in now and
an undying belief that we can get there
and to an absolute commitment to get us
there based on the values of the United
States our values were written down for
us all men are created equal endowed
with certain unalienable rights amongst
which include life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness and a constitution
was laid down for us a structural
document to help guide us how we can
achieve that ideal so our greatest
presidents have always been the ones
that believe in a vision that is
different than the world we're living in
now and a commitment and an optimism
that that version of the world they
imagined can exist and we will get there
within the boundaries of our own values
that's inspiring
and that's when we elect we elect to
join that we volunteer to be a part of
helping them build that vision now you
don't have to be the President of the
United States to work that way look at
Martin Luther King that's what he did he
offered us a vision we volunteered to
help him build that vision
we imagined with him and we committed
our own lives and I made our own
sacrifices to help advance that cause
that's what great presidents do they
literally lead us they lead us from here
to there and that of course involves
some of the issues but the issues of the
details that make us move from here to
there it's not about one issue or
another it's all the issues combined
that move the entire country from where
we are to where we want to go there's a
number of things that our current
presidents or potential future
presidents can learn from past
presidents one is that the best
presidents were American presidents they
weren't Republican presidents they
weren't Democrat presidents they were
presidents for the people of America and
once elected they saw themselves as
leaders for our country not leaders for
the party and when they were at their
best they believed an opportunity for
all of us not some of us right now the
way that they manifested it and maybe
the choices that they made in terms of
policy may have been informed or
influenced by their partisan beliefs but
their vision was American vision and all
of our greatest presidents always talked
about the opportunity for every one of
us and they believed it too the core of
their being and you can look to the past
they spoke in big broad general bright
terms and quite frankly the best
presidents were able to enjoy support
across the aisle I think that's one of
the things that made them great